cette célibataire qu'est ce que vous
recherchez souvient à part rien
spécialement si ça vient ça vient ça
vient pas ça vient pas voilà et
d'isabelle morini-bosc elle a attendu 80
pas donc en tout cas ce faire vous êtes
magnifique merci d'être avec nous votre
chroniqueur préféré
bah c'est mathieu mais bon c'est ça qui
m'a pas dit bonjour donc voilà bah oui
bah c'est le seul qui vous a pas dit
bonjour vous faites connaissance avec
mathieu parce que mathieu il n'a pas
idée en fait il a été happé je vais vous
dire pourquoi parce qu'à côté de vous
c'est pas du tout prévu en fait c'est
que y'a juste olic
[Rires]
il était jusqu à la moelle à cet
après-midi parce qu'on organisait les
vacances on va dire la vérité aux gens
voilà on a organisé les vacances de cet
été ensemble parce qu'on venait à faire
partir quelques jours ensemble est en
fête et la voile et m'a dit voitures de
seconde je me mets sur le canapé et si
tu sais moi je suis fan donc à chaque
fois je kiffe et ce voyage dans les
réunions je te vois travailler tout
c'est comme si je vais voir un pote dans
son lieu de travail donc ça me fait mal
je sais mais tu viens qu'autre chose
c'est un petit peu le stagiaire de 3e
aujourd'hui même titre not alone a été
est exceptionnel une fois de plus donc
on est en train de préparer les vacances
d'été
voilà j'espère série qui a appelé pour
un maison et tous voila j'ai trouvé un
petit logis et pour cet été pour qu'ils
puissent s'éclater
mais voilà il sera avec moi cet été et
ça sera nous faire du bien on va aller
chez décathlon je vous le dire comme
chaque été et chaque été on se voit et
on va chez décathlon on va acheter des
conneries lavalin classe dire à inciter
bien là la fois on s'est régalé c'est un
classique tous les étés ans à un
classique tous les étés on va chez
décathlon bola de marque
alors on va chez décathlon la voix la
soirée pizza à venir on va faire des
belles soirées people